um  [Music]  one day pirate just disappeared  [Music]  i couldn't find her anywhere  it was as if she vanished off the face  of all rest  without a trace  where have you gone  i'll find you whatever it takes  [Music]  this is where you were  sorry rex i couldn't tell you  because i got an invitation to join  trash  just sit back and leave it to me rex  behold the power of the egypt  [Music]  is  there are no pushovers  talk about a tight spot mithra  let me handle this  [Music]  mithra cutting it close huh  hey were these guys planning on running  gee  [Music]  foresight  [Music]  quite the spectacle aren't they wait  grumps  [Music]  [Music]  nailed it  shuck i never expected to see you two  again  well now that you're in smash  i won't go easy on you  you forget we're fighters too  you